good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight I'm will Kane in for
Tucker and it's a big day it's a big day
for the Irish and the president of the
United States would like to wish all of
you a happy Saint Patty
St Patrick's you know the thing
Joe Biden loves St Patrick's Day because
he's told us for decades he's Irish he's
even in the Irish American Hall of Fame
his secret service code name is Celtic
that's how Irish he is and Joe Biden's
proud of that here he was today with the
Irish Prime Minister every St Patrick's
Day
every Irishman goes out to find another
Irishman to make a speech to
well that's why I'm here I like all of
you take pride in my Irish ancestry and
as long as I can remember it's been sort
of part of my soul how I've been raised
he takes pride in his ancestry but he
did go on to joke that he's not really
Irish because well he's sober
and his family isn't in jail
at least not yet
because get it the Irish drink and they
get arrested a lot watch
I've been to Ireland many times but not
to actually look up to find my actual
family members and there are so many and
they actually weren't in jail they were
all but all kidding aside I met the
Lewis and the Finnegans and all of the
folks who were related to it I'm the
only Irishman you ever met though that's
never had a drink so I'm okay
I'm really not Irish
watching all this you have to wonder how
Joe Biden's countrymen in the Puerto
Rican Community are thinking tonight
for years Joe Biden has told us that
Puerto Ricans raised him and yet here he
is giving all the credit to the Irish
they probably feel pretty slighted in
Puerto Rico or maybe they're relieved
either way the facts of Joe Biden's
biography are getting harder and harder
to pin down you see it's not just the
Puerto Ricans who are being airbrushed
away what about all the polls I mean the
Greeks who played key roles in Joe
Biden's upbringing see when it's not St
Patrick's Day Joe Biden talks about them
a lot
you know I grew up in a heavily Irish
Catholic Community in Scranton
Pennsylvania in a heavily Italian Polish
Community in Claremont Delaware I also
want to acknowledge someone else who
means a great deal to our family Rabbi
Michael Beals of the congregation Beth
Shalom in Wilmington Delaware that's
where I received my education I probably
went to shul more than many of you did
foreign
we have a very in relative terms large
Puerto Rican population in Delaware I
was sort of raised in the Puerto Rican
community at home I got my education for
real in the black church and that's not
hyperbole is the fact I'm an honorary
Greek not only today
not only today
but every day black Puerto Rican Greek
pull Italian Jewish
Puerto Rican I think I said that one
twice we're just gonna have to take
Joe's word for it because it's Friday
and it's also kind of funny to imagine
this benaton of an upbringing if it were
true even though it's clearly not true
so we got to ask how does a Puerto Rican
Greek Irishman celebrate St Patty's Day
well we've been able to identify that
Joe Biden has something of a tradition
for this holiday
first he makes fun of the Irish while at
the same time bragging about himself
here was Joe Biden last year for example
you must be farther from about to sin
[Music]
I
foreign
well I just want you to know I may be
Irish but I'm not stupid I may be Irish
but I'm not stupid that was last year
this year I may be Irish but I'm not
drunk and in jail Joe Biden's been at
this for a while so the subtlety of his
insults is gone but back in the day Joe
Biden was more clever he found more
inventive ways to slight his Irish
guests on Saint Patrick's Day back in
2010 for example Biden memorialized the
mother of Ireland's prime minister
even though she was very much alive
the T-shirt knows a lot about it his mom
lived in in Long Island for 10 years or
so a God Rest her soul and uh
um although she's sweet your mom's still
your mom's still alive is your dad
passed
God bless her soul
I gotta get this straight
it's a big one to not have straight you
can feel I mean it's electric Joe
Biden's enthusiasm for St Patrick's Day
in these videos it's infectious in fact
as Kamala Harris told us today Joe
Biden's love of this holiday is
authentic and of course no one is better
to judge authenticity than Kamala Harris
watch
as you all know Vice President Biden
this was one of his most particular Joys
as vice president and as you all know he
is quite exuberant in that joy and I now
have caught the bug
Joe Biden takes St Patrick's Day
seriously I really can't talk I use my
hands a lot to talk but how seriously
does Joe Biden take St Patrick's Day we
can't confirm this but there are reports
tonight that Biden's famous Showdown
with Corn Pop resulted from Mr Pop not
having the proper reverence for St
Patrick's Day he refused to wear green
and Irish Joe had no choice but to teach
him a lesson and Corn Pop was a bad dude
and he ran a bunch of bad boys he said
I'll be waiting for you he was waiting
for three guys in straight razors not a
joke and he cut off a six foot length of
chain he fold up he said you walk out
with that chain
and you walked in a car and say you may
cut me man but I'm going to wrap this
chain around your head the truth that
truly is one of the greatest hits of
politics that clip never gets old it is
solid gold now again we cannot be sure
that Corn Pop had offended Joe Biden's
Irish Puerto Rican Greek polish Italian
ancestry but it's starting to look like
the most likely Theory subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight